foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory today we're going to be
discussing some breaking news regarding
the future of Harry Potter I made a
video just a few days ago discussing the
future of Fantastic Beasts and whether
or not we'd end up with the fourth and
fifth installment as originally planned
but while the future of Fantastic Beasts
is still very much uncertain exciting
news lies elsewhere as the CEO of Warner
Bros discovery recently revealed that he
wants to make more Harry Potter films
you heard me Harry Potter during a Q3
investors meeting this week CEO David
zazlov opened up about his Ambitions to
have the company working on further
Productions in The Wizarding World
pending the approval of JK Rowling we're
going to focus on franchises he said we
haven't had a Superman movie in 13 years
we haven't done a Harry Potter in 15
years the DC movies in the Harry Potter
movies provided a lot of the profits for
Warner Bros over the past 25 years he
added if we can do something with JK on
Harry Potter going forward the comment
was made while the CEO was discussing
the importance of franchises what are
the movies that have brands that are
understood and loved everywhere in the
world it's now been 11 years since the
studio has released a Harry Potter film
with the last installment Harry Potter
and the Deathly Hallows Part 2 being
released in 2011. however to say that
the Harry Potter films were a box office
success is a massive understatement
earning 7.7 billion globally between
2001 and 2011. Harry Potter is arguably
their most important IP so ignoring it
would be a big mistake while there are
no active discussions between Rowling
and the company in regards to Future
films zazlov's desire to create more
films is the first step and the first
glimpse of Hope we've had in years when
it comes to continuing Harry Potter
itself
and perhaps the Flop from the Fantastic
Beast franchise needed to happen to give
them some perspective we're now six
months post Seekers of Dumbledore and
there have been no mentions at all of a
fourth installment which combined with
the less than desirable box office
figures doesn't exactly inspire a lot of
confidence if the studio were to create
a new Harry Potter film what would you
want to see the origins of Tom Riddle a
Marauders film there are so many options
to explore leave a comment down below
with what you'd like to see until next
time remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live
foreign
[Music]